coca-cola and delta slam georgia's voter
bill as the woke left cheers
the biden administration struggles to
explain how they will deal with human
smugglers tossing children over the
border and aoc says it's time to spend
10 trillion dollars i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government's
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first this is your reminder
that those big tech companies they don't
like you very much
and they're using your data in order to
monetize their dislike of you so why
exactly would you give them your data to
monetize
turning on incognito or private mode and
chrome or safari that's not enough
it doesn't matter how often you clear
your browsing history your isp internet
service provider can see every single
website you've ever visited
they can sell your data to advertisers
that's why i use expressvpn to keep my
online data secure
and private expressvpn makes sure your
isp and third-party trackers can't see
your online activity and location
it does that by rerouting your
connection through a secure encrypted
server in fact
expressvpn protects all your data
regardless of whether you use incognito
mode
at all expressvpn has you covered easy
to use apps for computers and mobile
devices so you can use the internet with
confidence all you've got to do
you tap one button now you are protected
expressvpn
is the fastest most trusted vpn on the
market which is why they are rated
number one
by cnet and wired as well i use
expressvpn every time i go online
you should too protect your online
activity today with the vpn i trust to
keep
myself private visit expressvpn.com
ben you can get an extra three months
free on a one year package that's
expressvpn.com
ben to learn more all right so there
is this perspective on the right that
has started to crop up
sort of from the anti-trump right i
would say it's cropped up more and more
recently over recent months
and over recent years and that is that
people on the right who are focused
on the culture wars are people who are
not focused on the real issues
and i think what these people feel fail
to appreciate is that the culture war
is the real issue it really is because
culture is upstream of politics
and if you think that simply fighting in
favor of
particular forms of voter bills or
fighting in favor of particular views of
economics is enough
that is absolutely wrong and the reason
it's absolutely wrong is because the
culture around us
is changing the culture around us is
shifting and that culture is now being
inculcated it is now being
interwoven it's being infused into every
institution in american life
and so it won't matter what kind of
bills you pass when it turns out that
every major institution
immediately reacts to those bills by
trying to cut off
the republican party or conservatives or
anyone they disagree with
at the knees when it turns out the media
won't report the truth when it turns out
that your corporate overlords demand
fuel to you or they will fire you
when it turns out that the education
system
your entertainment system when all of
those things militate
against everything that you believe in
legislatively on economics it does not
matter what you believe in on economics
anymore
the battle has to be first won within
the institutions then you can talk about
what exactly is the policy that ought to
be promulgated
yes policy matters but you know what
matters more the durability of the
policy because you can pass something
today
and if you have a culture that is
shifted around you it doesn't matter one
iota
this is what you see even in leftist
places like california you'll remember
that in 2008 proposition 8 in california
passed proposition 8 was a proposition
to enshrine traditional marriage of the
law in california
it passed fairly sought with solid
numbers and within a few years
anybody who had even supported
proposition 8 was being thrown out of a
job
brennan ice over at mozilla firefox
famously supported proposition 8. by the
way
so did barack obama at the time he was
in favor of traditional marriage
and yet within just a few years even
having supported it
even though it was a majority position
in 2008 meant that you are now some sort
of societal pariah
so when people on the right say why are
we fighting the culture words it's a
distraction it's a distraction from the
real issues
no the culture war is the real issue and
all of the legislation
is an outgrowth of the culture wars and
that's something that people on the
right i think inherently recognize
it's why the traditional republican
party has shifted i think
actually in some positive ways around
this stuff i think for a long time the
republican party was just the party of
build up the military and cut taxes and
i think now there are more and more
republican politicians who understand
that a lot of these battles
aren't fought at the legislative level
level a lot of these battles are fought
at the cultural level
now it may be a misalignment it may be
the politicians aren't the best people
to fight these battles but it is
certainly true that if the right doesn't
fight these battles they're going to
lose
and it's why the right feels like it's
under assault because the right is under
assault
so just to take the most obvious example
over the last 48 hours
lester holt who is the the nightly news
anchor over at nbc news
lester holt was given the edgar r the
edward
r murrow award and in the middle of his
speech he announced that he was no
longer going to try to bother to cover
both sides of any particular issue
because some sides are true and some
sides are false this is the way that
people on the left
will massage themselves into never
having to grant the credibility of
another side even existing
this is dangerous stuff in other words
when you have a media that is fully
bought into the idea
that it is quote unquote both scientism
to actually represent both sides of a
particular issue
then that's the media just excusing its
own partisanship now if the media wants
to be partisan that is totally fine that
is their prerogative they can be
partisan
we're partisan here's daily wire i'm a
partisan host i don't make any bones
about it
the difference is i'm not dishonest
about it members of our establishment
media are
they're hijacking an institution the
institution of quote unquote objective
media
and they are doing so on behalf of the
left in order to
vitiate the power of the right in the
societal discourse here's lester hold
basically undermining journalism
i think it's become clear that fairness
is overrated
well before you run off and tweet that
headline let me explain a bit
the idea that we should always give two
sides equal weight and merit does not
reflect the world we find ourselves in
that the sun sets in the west is a fact
and a contrary view does not deserve our
time or attention
providing an open platform for
misinformation for anyone to come say
whatever they want especially when
issues of public health and safety are
at stake can be quite dangerous
now listen there do have to be limits to
what you think
should be reported because you can't
report literally every view on every
single issue there's just not time
but the problem here is that when innate
bias comes in when inherent bias comes
in
now the sort of the sort of confirmation
bias that you see in the media all the
time the natural tendency for people on
the left is to assume that everybody on
the right is saying stuff that is not
true and everybody on the left is
telling you the truth
and that is generally a lie it is
generally a lie the bad administration
has been lying like a rug
since they entered office and yet
they've been given all the credibility
that is unwarranted and yet if you take
an opposing point of view then this is
treated as somehow
misinformation and the natural result of
this is silencing
this is why facebook and instagram have
now non-person to trump according to the
uk
daily mail facebook and instagram have
actually removed a donald trump
interview with his daughter-in-law lara
in another sign of the left-leaning
silicon valley giants canceling the
former president in the interview trump
tore into social media and the
mainstream media
for suppressing the hunter biden laptop
story he criticized president biden's
green agenda
and railed against cancel culture which
he said obliterates us culture
he did this for the right view which is
lara's show during the 18-minute
interview
trump also spoke about running for
president again in 2024. lara had been
promoting it on facebook instagram and
twitter
beforehand at 9 26 p.m on tuesday night
four minutes before it was due to be
uploaded
facebook emailed lara team warning that
it would be removed if it went live at 9
51 pm they emailed again to say they
would they had taken it down
trump has been banned from twitter
facebook and instagram since the january
6th riot cut off from his supporters
unable to get messages to them
in the way he did before in their email
the facebook employee said quote content
posted in the voice of president trump
is not currently allowed on our
platforms including new posts with
president trump speaking
and will be removed okay we're not no
longer talking about trump's account
having been suspended here which by the
way should not have been done
we are not talking about trump putting
out via his own auspices
his point of view we are talking about a
person who has not been banned
interviewing trump and that content
being taken down
that is wild stuff that is the the
complete
the the description of unpersoning as in
like george orwell's 1984
that is an accurate description of what
is going on right now
trump's interview with lara was the
first time he'd been seen on camera
since he left office
he'd been phoning into fox news to share
his opinions i haven't explained why it
is
that his actual face has to just be
taken down you can't actually hear
the voice of the former president of the
united states on an outlet that is not
his own
that's pretty incredible stuff but i
guess that falls under the rubric for
the media of
you can't have people lying you can't
have people lying and here is the thing
it is only certain types of lies that
the media get very upset with other
types of lies they are happy
to to facilitate they are happy to
promulgate themselves we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about something amazing you can do for
your family so
hanging above one of the couches in our
home
is this beautiful portrait of me and my
wife and two of our three children
we got it from paintyourlife.com it's a
truly meaningful gift you get a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo
at a truly affordable price you can
choose from a team of world-class
artists you can work with them until
every detail is perfect
their user-friendly platform lets you
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait
in less than five minutes you can send
any picture yourself kids family special
place cherished pet
or you can combine photos into one
painting it makes the perfect birthday
anniversary or wedding gift
it's meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love that
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now his limited
time offer get twenty percent off your
painting that's right twenty percent off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word ben
to sixty four thousand that has been to
sixty four thousand
text ben to sixty four thousand paint
your life celebrate the moments that
matter most it is an awesome gift again
we have one in our house i have to get a
new one actually because we have a new
baby
get one right now it's really cool terms
apply available at paintyourlife.com
terms again text ben to 64 000 to get
started on
a fabulous gift that really is super
meaningful okay so there's only certain
types of lies
that the media are unwilling to report
it is only certain types of perspectives
media are willing to silence if the
biden administration lies and lies and
lies again
the media will sometimes report that
it's a lie although it'll take them
quite a while
but mostly they will amplify the lie
until at the bottom of page 813
they add a little correction at the
bottom so to take an example
the media have lied over and over and
over about this georgia voting bill
why well because the democrats have been
lying over and over and over about this
georgia voting bill this georgia voting
bill
is not a transformative bill in fact in
some ways it actually broadens
the ability for people to vote the only
thing that the bill does in terms of
quote unquote limiting
people's ability to vote and doesn't
limit anybody's ability to vote is
it requires voter id it requires voter
id for absentee ballots
which makes sense because you don't want
people voting without being able to
verify who they are
it actually lengthens voting hours in
certain places and it says you're not
allowed to bribe people in line
there's much belly hood line about how
you're not allowed to give people water
in line
no you are allowed to give people water
in line just not within a certain
distance of the polling place and has
quote unquote a gift
okay that is what the language of the
statute suggests it is not about
somebody stepping out of line to get a
cup of water or something or are you
sending a member of your family to go
get a cup of water that is not what this
is talking about it's talking about
a guy with a biting t-shirt walking up
to everybody at the front of the line
and handing them a water bottle this is
biden
2024 right that is what the the bill is
talking about
but the administration's been lying
about this because they have to create a
myth
it is it remains incredible to me that
the media have suggested since november
that voter fraud and voter irregularity
these are things that do not exist and
if you even suggest they exist
then you have to be banned from social
media however what does exist is voter
suppression when there is
literally no evidence of widespread
voter suppression in the united states
none none okay anybody who tells you
there's widespread voter suppression in
the united states is lying to you
but because the media love the agenda
because the media are interested in the
agenda they will promote that lie
at all costs they are happy to promote
they are excited to promote that lie
they love that lie that lie is super
wonderful according to the media
because after all that's how they
promote things like the for the people
act hr one which is complete federal
takeover voting procedures a loosening
of federal procedures
a mandate of ballot harvesting across
the country which as i say is the single
greatest opportunity for voter fraud and
irregularity that i've ever seen
they need to to promote a false crisis
in order to
push a particular solution it's the same
thing by the way that the cdc is now
doing with regard to covid so we know
for a fact according to the data that
people who are vaccinated are generally
not transmitting the disease when i say
generally i mean
it is it is extraordinarily rare for
people who have been vaccinated
to try to either be able to get coveted
in the first place or to transmit
covenant in fact the cdc
had said that earlier this week earlier
this week rochelle lenski of the cdc
openly explained
that if you're vaccinated you're not
passing it well today the cdc walked it
back the cdc walked it back not based on
the data and not based on the science
they walked it back because joe biden
wants another two rounds of trans
spending he wants another two tranches
of spending and he can't get that
spending done
unless crisis mentality is on the table
well the same thing is true when it
comes to voting the left has to promote
the lie that there is widespread voter
suppression across the country
this is why everybody gets very angry
when i point out that there is no
widespread voter suppression across the
country
like the evidence of widespread voter
suppression is significantly less
than the evidence that there is voter
fraud and regularity across the country
and there ain't that much evidence
of widespread voter fraud and regularity
across the country this is coming from
somebody who didn't believe that stuff
okay but if you mention that then again
the goal here
is it's about what democrats want to do
so what crisis what fake crisis do we
have to generate today
in order to generate support for this
piece of wide-ranging legislation that
we don't actually need
okay so certain lies in pursuance
of of the goal that's okay according to
the media so jen sackey
remember how refreshing she was
transparent never forget when jen
sackey entered office when the biden
administration entered office there was
a spate of articles
about how jenn sackey was super honest
even though she'd been a liar during the
obama administration
about how this biden administration was
going to be incredibly transparent they
are significantly less
transparent than the trump
administration about how this was going
to be a refreshing new day the
professionals were here they were in
charge
and now the media have changed their
tune but only to the extent that many of
the media like jen rubin over the
washington post
will suggest that the real problem is
that people keep asking questions just
stop asking questions guys okay so
yesterday jen sackey went to the white
house podium and she just started lying
openly about this georgia law
now biden has lied so openly that even
the washington post which loves joe
biden which
carries around a drool cup for joe biden
which is second in the human centipede
to joe biden which is a messy job even
the washington post had given four
pinocchios the other day because he
suggested
that the georgia law had somehow limited
voting hours which is simply not true
they'd given four pinocchios for that
that didn't stop john sackey from
getting out there and lying about it
again she doesn't know anything about
the georgia voting law all she knows is
that it's bad and she knows it's bad
because they're pushing hr1
and because this is a wonderful way of
suggesting to black americans that
somehow their votes won't be counted in
georgia
a state in which two democratic senators
were just elected
in large measure because of increased
black turnout here is jen sackey lying
about the georgia voting bill
it also makes it so that uh outside
groups can't provide water or food to
people in line
right no it makes it more difficult to
absentee vote
no those things all correct is seven to
seven
and early voting can standardize adding
saturday and sunday so
my question is is the tone going to
change out of the white house or
the tone for a bill that limits voting
access and makes it more difficult for
people to engage in voting
in georgia no that's actually not what
the uh the governor of georgia has said
well i think that is not based in fact
what the governor of georgia has said so
no our tone is not changing
um your tone is not changing because you
are lying you
are lying it is not true okay the fact
is they've expanded
the voting ability on sundays for
example in new jersey you can vote
i think nine days before an election in
georgia it's 17 days
is new jersey engaged in jim crow voter
suppression
of course not okay but it's never about
whether the democrats are telling the
truth it's about how they wield power
this is what i started with when it
comes to the culture war
it's about the wielding of power
particularly power outside the
government now
because what the left has realized is
that they have to play an inside outside
game
what they have to do is gain government
power
by essentially telling private industry
that if they go along to get along they
will be the last
people eaten the democratic party is an
alligator and corporations have decided
they are going to feed the alligators so
as to not be eaten
they'll be eaten last okay but the thing
is they're not going to be eaten last so
how does this manifest it manifests in
major corporations like delta and
coca-cola just being completely
dishonest so delta and coca-cola have
decided that they are very angry with
the georgia voter law now one thing that
you will note here
is that delta and coca-cola had nothing
to say about the georgia voter law until
after it was passed
they had nothing to say about it so
they're perfectly fine with the voter
law
it is only now that there is blow back
from the left that they've decided
they're going to cave to the woke left
they're going to do whatever the left
wants them to do
as karen townsend writes over at hot air
the manufactured outrage over georgia
governor brian kemp signing voting law
reform
has reached the point of satisfying no
one now the backlash includes black
executives facing a very basic question
along with ceos of large corporations
who are now opposing the bill
where were you when the bill was being
written and debated in the state
legislature
why is opposition only happening after
the governor signed the legislation into
effect
so delta put out a statement the airline
put out a statement condemning the voter
bill now i have a question
the hell does georgia have to what the
hell does delta have to do with anything
delta is an employer in georgia yeah so
it's like bob's burger who the hell
cares what delta has to say about
anything
they are an airline they have nothing to
say about
various voter id restrictions
like does delta sound off on every piece
of legislation or only the legislation
where people on the walk left a
lot
and i think the answer is pretty obvious
here delta had made only general
statements according to the new york
times
in support of voting rights last week
they declined to take a position on the
legislation which by the way is the
proper attitude because they are a
private business
it's so funny the same left that will
tell you that it is corporate corruption
to donate money from a corporation to a
candidate will tell you that every
corporation has to openly sound off in
support of their policies or
be forced into a position being
boycotted their failure to condemn the
bill it wasn't even that they backed the
bill
their failure to condemn the bill drew
fierce criticism as well as protests
at hartsfield-jackson atlanta
international airport and calls for a
boycott
and because delta pansied out they
decided to cave to this stuff
on wednesday ed bastian delta's chief
executive made a stark reversal quote
i need to make it crystal clear that the
final bill is unacceptable and does not
match delta's values
you know what he should have said to all
of these protesters you're not buying
tickets anyway
no one gives a crap what you have to say
you think anybody is seriously
boycotting delta the great lie about
these boycotts is that they work they do
not work the amount of actual financial
damage done by the so-called boycotters
in virtually all of these scenarios is
nearly nothing
it's just that delta doesn't feel like
dealing with the bad publicity from the
left and the left is super loud and the
media are super annoying and so they
feel like okay well if i buy them off
with some
statement about georgia law that doesn't
actually change georgia law today
maybe they'll leave me alone except they
won't they know that they've got your
neck in the news and now they're just
going to tighten the news every time
georgia does anything that they don't
like
you are going to be expected to side
with the woke if georgia passes a law
protecting human life
in the womb you're going to be expected
to s to sound off about how terrible
georgia is at bastion and they're going
to bully you until you either leave the
state
or until you declare that you are openly
in favor of democrats being elected
we moved real fast from your speech is
violence to silence is violence right
this is the game the left like to play
is that if you speak out in a way they
don't like that is a form of violence
but also
if you stay silent that is also violence
in other words the only way
they will let you off the hook is if you
become part of the board is if you start
to mirror the woke mob
coca-cola had also declined to take a
position on legislation before it passed
because they are a soda company they
made a similarly worded statement
james quincy coca-cola's chief executive
said i want to be crystal clear
the coca-cola company does not support
this legislation as it makes it harder
for people to vote not easier that is
just
a lie there is nothing in the bill that
makes it difficult to vote
i'm sorry you need to show an id to buy
a bottle of beer
in georgia you should be after you
should have to show id in order to vote
your voting actually impacts the country
in a way that you being a drunk does not
this is ridiculous nonsense less than a
day before the abrupt reversals a group
of prominent black executives called on
companies to publicly oppose a wave of
similarly restricted voting bills
republicans are advancing in almost
every state they are not restricted
voting bills there is nothing here
that makes it incredibly difficult to
vote this is just
its sheer ridiculousness there are
people all around the world who have
actually had to
brave bullets to vote i'm sorry you
stood in line
for an additional 45 minutes to vote
that does not count as voter suppression
i'm sorry you actually had to find an id
my god you have an id oh no that's clear
none of this is suppression of the vote
but it doesn't matter it's not about
that it's about the narrative the
narrative is that if you want to push
any form of voter verification this
means that you're a racist
all this plays into the broader white
supremacy lie that is being promulgated
every single day by the left and the
equity lie pushed by the biden
administration
darren walker president of the ford
foundation and board member at ralph
lauren pepsi and square said
it is regrettable that the sense of
urgency came after the legislation was
passed and signed into law
mr bastian decided to write the memo and
revise the company's position on tuesday
night
after speaking with kenneth chinolt a
former executive of
american express who helped organize
this statement by black executives
according to three people
familiar with the conversation again
black americans are not being suppressed
in the vote in georgia it is a lie it is
not true this is not a jim crow
restriction
it is significantly more permissive than
many of the laws around the nation and
black people
are are voting in outsized numbers in
georgia you can't have it both ways it
can't be that stacey abrams did an
unbelievable job organizing the black
vote and got out the black vote at
record lovers
levels and also black voters are being
disenfranchised
mr bastian went further he said the new
law was based on false pretenses he said
the entire rationale for the bill was
based on a lie that there was widespread
voter fraud in georgia in the 2020
elections that's not true
or alternatively brian kemp who didn't
uphold that lie
backs the bill because people should
have to show id when they vote
in a second we will show you the
unbelievable hypocrisy
of these ceos because as it turns out
they are not sincere
in their objections to this law they're
just pandering as always
okay so coca-cola's ceo he said this is
a step backward
it's a step backward well i think we
should take him at face value after all
woca-cola now mirrors the left
priorities we've seen their diversity
training seminars here is a little bit
of the coca-cola ceo
this legislation is unacceptable
it is a step backwards and it does not
promote principles we have stood for in
georgia
around broad access to voting around
voter convenience
about ensuring election integrity and
this is this is frankly just a step
backwards
we've spent many decades uh promoting
uh within georgia a better society and a
better environment for business and this
is a step backwards
okay no you guys are just cowards that's
all that's happening here you're just
absolute benighted cowards
these corporations are are filled with
cowards top to bottom
they're afraid of discrimination
lawsuits so they have these diversity
training seminars that do not alleviate
discrimination
they're afraid of a few hashtags on
twitter
which never actually amount to anything
and so they just
cower in the corner hoping that people
will go away it's just sheer
brazen cowardice
these folks are they're just ridiculous
they're just ridiculous
but if you get enough people to sign a
statement then presumably that shifts
the culture and if the culture has
shifted
then you have to have then people will
start to shift their opinion on it now
here's the thing
they don't give a crap about this law
they don't care about the law all
they're trying to do is avoid scrutiny
because when it comes to
places they do care about they are
perfectly willing to green light
open human rights violation remember
back in november of 2020 okay just a few
months ago
nike and coca-cola woke a cola here that
says that it is a human rights violation
to show voter id and that it is a deep
brutality what is happening in georgia
coca-cola was lobbying against a bill
that would crack down on forced labor in
zhang
according to the new york times quote
nike and coca-cola are among the major
companies and business groups lobbying
congress to weaken a bill that would ban
imported goods made with forced labor in
china's xinjiang region
according to congressional staff members
and other people familiar with the
matter
the legislation called the uyghur forced
labor prevention act has become the
target of multinational companies
including apple
lobbyists have fought to water down some
of his provisions arguing that while
they strongly condemn forced labor
and current atrocities in zhang jiang
the act's ambitious requirements could
wreak havoc on supply chains that are
deeply embedded
in china human rights groups and news
reports have linked many multinational
corporations to suppliers they're
including tying coca-cola
to sugar sourced from zhang jiang so
just to get this free coca-cola is fine
with forced labor and zhanjang so long
as they get the sugar from jean chang
but being based in georgia as coca-cola
is
whereas delta is and coca-cola having
the temerity to pass a voter law that
does not prevent people from voting
that of course is a major major problem
remember
woca-cola is so woke they openly thanked
china on the pandemic
quote this is kurt ferguson the
president of coca-cola for greater china
and korea quote
thank you very much to the government
with your quick decisive actions once
again thank you
you've really controlled the worldwide
epidemic and should be very much
congratulated
for all of your hard work that was in
march of 2020.
yeah they did a great job containing
covet as it turns out
all of this is about leveraging social
pressure from the outside
in order to count legislators into
submission and mostly in order cow
voters it's really not it's not about
coke
it is not about delta it's about coke
and delta saying things
to force you into submission it's about
you the employee
of coca-cola it is about you the
employee of delta
is about you the normal citizen of
georgia who's now being told
by all of the leaders in your society
from corporations
to churches to newspapers to your
government
that you are a bad person if you support
this georgia legislation
this is why you have joe biden moderate
joe biden remember he's not a culture
warrior
remember the democrats are never culture
warriors on these republicans with their
stupid culture
joe biden said on espn that the major
league baseball should relocate their
all-star game from atlanta
in order to punish georgia for having
passed this voter id law now this is
nothing new
you've seen the left attempt to do this
before the ncaa attempted to remove
basketball games from north carolina
when a bill passed that would have
prevented
localities from allowing biological men
into women's bathrooms
so you've seen private industry attempt
to leverage
legislation that they like or that they
don't like
now biden is encouraging this this is
the inside outside game mlb
you know we're in charge of the
government it would be really great if
you guys would
really use your leverage in order to do
what we want and corporations
which again are not about freedom this
is the dirty secret people on the right
because they believe that corporations
and big business they are business
and they are free enterprise
institutions
they believe that those people who run
those corporations are into free
enterprise
that is not the case they're into profit
there's a difference between profit and
free enterprise
free enterprise is the idea that there
should be fewer regulations
generally even if that hurts your
business because you ought to compete in
the marketplace
many corporate heads are not in favor of
that many corporate heads are in favor
of subsidies from the government
they're in favor of tax breaks from the
government they're in favor of the
government patting them on the head
and working with them to suppress their
competition so corporations are deeply
afraid of the government and are happy
to work with the government if the
government passed them on the head and
gives them a scooby treat
so joe biden is doing that right now
remember major league baseball
is in fact reliant on anti-trust
exemptions that have been granted by the
federal government
so they do have something to fear here
so joe biden says the major league
baseball should relocate their all-star
game the politicization of every area of
american life because democrats hope to
hope to weaponize every institution in
american life this is why you feel under
assault this is why the culture wars
matter here's joe biden saying something
utterly immoderate
old joe here moderate old joe what do
you think about the possibility that
baseball
decides to move their all-star game out
of atlanta because of
this political issue
i think today's professional athletes
are acting incredibly responsibly
i would strongly support them doing that
people look to them
they're leaders look at what's happened
with the nba as well
this is jim crow on steroids what
they're doing in
in georgia and 40 other states that is
such a despicable statement
jim crow as in like black people and
white people can't use the same water
fountains
as in like you know let's unofficially
allow people to go and terrorize black
people so they can't vote
you know disgusting it is that this
perverse
elderly gentleman keeps suggesting that
what is happening in georgia is in any
way akin to jim crow
it's an absurdity at the highest level
it's a it's a devaluation of how evil
jim crow was
and it's a degradation of who georgians
are it's disgusting
and the fact that he's allowed to get
away with the jim crow is there going to
be any fact check from the media
is lester holt's going to do a fact
check on the differences between jim
crow
where he had segregated schools and a
voting law that applies to every single
person in georgia who can vote
of course you won't get that fact check
there's only one side of the aisle
matters when it comes to truth
and fact checking brian kemp the
governor of georgia he points out this
is all ridiculous the hell are you
talking about
what joe biden needs to do is look at
the side by side
of georgia and delaware you know he's
focused on trying to get major league
baseball to pull the game out of georgia
which is ridiculous
if you look at these comparisons the
state of delaware
has no in-person early voting we have 17
days
in georgia you don't have to have an
excuse to get an absentee ballot by mail
in delaware you do we have drop boxes
delaware does not and if you want to get
a bottle of water while you're standing
in line in georgia you can absolutely do
that the elections officials
can help you with that but you can't do
that in delaware because they don't have
early voting and and yet this is not the
line you will hear from the media
you'll hear from the media that this is
like jim crow anybody who tells you like
this is like jim crow
anybody who says that should immediately
be cast out of the public conversation
for being a damned liar it is a damned
lie
and the media are telling that lie over
and over they're allowing abiding to
tell that lie
over and over it's disgusting it's
disgusting and when joe biden says
that we should have athletes lead the
way here and then he praises the nba
yeah you notice i noticed a few things
about the nba
over the past you know few years i
noticed for example that if you're in
the nba and you're anti-semitic and
you're kevin durant or
lebron james you get totally away with
it i noticed also that if you're kevin
durant or lebron james or anybody else
in the nba
and you put equity on the back of your
basketball jersey this means that you
can then
just laugh and and cash the check while
china subjects hong kong
to complete tyranny i also noticed that
you can
and moan about lack of equal pay
and then you can take home your 43
million dollar check while sue bird
of the seattle storm is taking home home
215 000 you're a bunch of damn
hypocrites you're ridiculous
you're ridiculous on your face it's
insane and these are our moral leaders
but again it's all about creating a
culture in which we pretend that these
people are our moral leaders and the
media backing this
to the hilt now there are ways that
people on the right can fight back and
should fight back
i'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
your sleep quality may be not great
these days a lot of stress
in the world right now but if you've
been listening to the show for a while
you've probably heard me talk about my
sleep quality via my helix sleep
mattress helix mattresses are absolutely
fantastic but here's the thing
helix is not just doing mattresses
anymore they've gone beyond the bedroom
they started making
sofas they just launched a new company
it's called all form they're making
premium customizable sofas
and shares shipped directly to your door
so what makes an all form sofa really
cool well a bunch of things for starters
it's the easiest way you can customize
the sofa using premium materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric it is
spill stain scratch resistant super
useful if you've got kids the way i do
the sofa color color of the legs
sofa size shape make sure it's perfect
for you and your home they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
eight seat sectional
there's something for everybody and you
can always start small and then you can
add on later you can buy more seats
later if you want your all form sofa to
grow
and change with you when you move all
form sofas delivered directly to your
door
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa you need to hire somebody to come
assemble it for you well all form has
simple quick assembly no tools needed i
have an all form sofa i picked out a
three-seat sofa with chase and the sand
color with espresso legs it is awesome
it is so comfortable people want to
sleep on that
it's either the helix mattress or that's
what people want to lie on if getting a
sofa
without trying it in store sounds risky
don't worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months if you don't love it i'll
pick it up for free
give you a full refund they have a
forever warranty literally for the rest
of your days
all form is offering 20 off all orders
for our listeners at allform.com that's
all form dot com slash men can't
testify highly enough to how great they
are all form.com
ben go check them out right now
allform.com
ben it's a great sofa it really is
alright in a second we're gonna get to
how georgia republicans are fighting
back then we'll get to
the biden administration basically
having very little to say about um
border smugglers throwing babies
first as you've probably heard candace
joined the daily wire a few weeks ago
with the premiere of her new talk show
candace the show streams on
dailywire.com fridays at 9 pm eastern
apm central you get the audio podcast
canvas
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast candace hosts a series
of guests on the show every week making
for lively panel discussions and
insightful interviews uh my favorite
part of candace's show
she's got something she calls the cancel
corner in which she sort of speaks
directly to camera it's pretty fantastic
featured guests have included jocko
willing brandon tatum john rich to name
a few
candace is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live audience but
don't worry if you can't attend the show
in person tweet your questions
to at the candice show for a chance to
have candace answer your question at the
end of the show so
if you need some candice owens in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review
if you like what you hear join now so
you can hear her friday night
and check out her show you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
alrighty so the good news is that some
georgian
legislators are now pushing back on some
of this corporate nonsense
the corporate echoing of woke garbage
lies
according to the hill georgia
republicans on wednesday took a
last-minute swipe at delta
after the company's chief executive
criticized a massive measure of
overhauling voting rules
in the waning hours of the legislative
session the georgia state house passed a
bill to repeal a tax break on jet fuel
and squarely one of the state's largest
companies and the largest operator
flights into
and out of hartsfield jackson airport
you know what good seriously good
in the past i'd be very much opposed to
legislators
basically giving privileges or denying
privilege based on politics but once
these corporations
start to simply echo the lies of the
left and they start to use their thumb
and put it on the political scale
then legislators are well within their
rights to say listen you don't like it
there go your special privileges you
want special privileges from the left
you get to deal with them now
enjoy dan patrick who's the lieutenant
governor
of texas he just came out similarly
today and he smacked
american airlines because american
airlines put out a statement ripping on
senate bill 7 in texas
which is a bill dealing with voter id
for example he put out a statement said
texans are fed up with corporations that
don't share our values trying to dictate
public policy
the majority of texans support
maintaining the integrity of our
elections that's why i made it a
priority this legislative session senate
bill 7 includes comprehensive reforms
that will ensure voting in texas
is consistent statewide and secure by
the way this is the same american
airlines that in 2017
led the fight to try to force us to
allow boys to play girls sports in texas
and take away their scholarships they're
probably still fighting for that today
it's likely they have not read senate
bill 29 either
if corporations are going to become
political then they are going to be
subjected to the same
sort of scrutiny as everybody else in
the political space
and that's the way this works you don't
get to dip your toe in without actually
entering the waters
and you certainly don't get to do that
on a one-sided political
along one-sided political lines and then
hope that the other side just doesn't
smack you
the right's going to have to smack back
it's the only way this is going to work
because otherwise it's just going to
continue okay in
in just a second we'll talk about border
policy here so
meanwhile when it comes to border policy
the biden administration simply has no
plan at the border they're not going to
do anything at the border
their encouragement their open
encouragement of people to search at the
border yes it's a surge
aoc and it doesn't mean insurgent needs
a surge
means lots of people are coming to the
border that is an overt policy it was
created by the biden administration now
they're denying it but they have no plan
to solve it here's retired acting ice
director tom homan
pointing out that joe biden was briefed
and knew that his changes in policy
would actually create this surge
this was totally preventable you know
the administration the income
administration was
they said if you if you end these
programs we're going to see a surge that
you've never seen before
they were briefed by leadership at ice
at cbp
i've talked to people that briefed them
and and so they knew this would happen
look uh brian i wrote outfit in july of
last year saying this would happen at
the end of these policies
they knew what they were doing again
this isn't but this isn't incompetence
this isn't
you know bad management this is open
borders
that is correct in fact how open are the
borders right now how bad is the
situation
border agency released videos of
toddlers being chucked
over the new mexico border wall like
physically thrown over the new mexico
border walls what we're about to show
next is a disturbing footage
but you're about to see smugglers
literally throwing babies
throwing toddlers there they are
sitting on top of the wall and literally
just dropping toddlers that's like a
what maybe a 10-foot drop 12-foot drop
there
you can see the toddler's lying on the
ground
there they are sitting right there on
top of that border wall
and um boom just dropping a toddler
just dropping a toddler so no problems
here everything is fine
everything is good jen sackey was asked
about this she had no answers other than
i don't like that babies are being
thrown how about this how about you
actually create some policy that
disincentivizes babies from being thrown
across the border
you know you it turns out that you are
the party in the white house
it turns out that you are running policy
right now here's jen sackey with no
answers
i've seen the video and i think any of
us who saw the video
um were incredibly alarmed by uh
the steps of smugglers ones that we have
been quite familiar with that we've
spoken out about our concerns
about as secretary mayorka said the
inhumane way smugglers abuse children
while profiting off parents desperation
is criminal
and morally reprehensible there's a lot
of issues and steps we need to take to
address root causes
so of course our concern is for the
safety of these kids
no it isn't it isn't if you're concerned
for the safety of the kids you'd be
disincentivizing people from chucking
kids over the border
i mean you have you literally have made
no policy recommendations and by the way
the radical left of your party
is openly open borders ilhan omar
who again poses on the cover of rolling
stone magazine with nancy pelosi
she says we have a moral and legal
responsibility to provide opportunity
for kids who are being chucked across
the border that's not going to increase
the search at the border or anything
here's ilhan omar
they're here because they are seeking
asylum
and looking for a shot at the american
dream
a lot of them have family members here
already that they're looking
to reconnect that they haven't seen and
have been separated from for a really
long time
and so to me this really is a is a
reminder that
we have a moral and legal legal
um to to provide that opportunity uh
for for these kids no we have a legal
responsibility to reunite them with
their parents
we have we have a legal responsibility
to reunite them with the parents who
sent them
across the desert that we do have a
legal responsibility to do what we don't
have a legal responsibility to do is
make them citizens you keep saying stuff
like this people are going to rush the
border this is not a giant shock
okay the radical left is in control of
this party and joe biden is just the
elderly
the elderly adult face of this that's
all this is
i will note this is kind of a funny
story the woke left is so woke at this
point that barack obama is not woke
enough
according to hot air an effort to rename
two schools
in waukegan illinois ran into a buzzsaw
of opposition when the waukegan board of
education took public comments on the
finalists for thomas jefferson middle
school
the author of the constitution will be
removed from the school for his
participation
in slavery or the declaration of
independence but latin x activists
demanded that barack and michelle obama
be removed from consideration as well
because obama is the quote unquote
supporter in chief so good to know that
barack obama is not woke enough for the
woke activists
meanwhile there is no limit to what the
woke activists would like to do here
alexander ocasio-cortez
in the aftermath of joe biden suggesting
that we spend you know two trillion
dollars on mostly useless crap
including 80 billion dollars for a
monorail
we're just we're just the simpsons now
joe biden is coming in monroe monterey
and washington's like you know what we
need more rail because he likes amtrak
yeah we like
yes that's clearly what america needs is
more monorails
i like trains but unlike p booty judge
that does not make me qualified to be
secretary of transportation what i do
know is that spending
80 billion dollars on rail is the
stupidest thing that i have heard
recently
it is idiocy beyond that
as dan mclaughlin points out over a
national review everything that comes
from washington dc costs more than the
price tag
if you take that two trillion dollar
number at face value and combine it with
the 1.9 trillion dollars biden the
democrats spends in their coveted relief
bill we are talking about 32
000 of new spending for every household
in the united states that's more than
all the wealth of all the nation's
billionaires put together you put that
on top
of our annual 4.48 trillion dollar
budget before you add in another 2
trillion on education child care and
social program
spending reportedly on the way aoc says
the biden plan is not nearly enough
here is aoc saying you know what we need
we need 10 trillion dollars 10 trillion
because money has no meaning anymore
the rules of gravity have been suspended
that's the magic of joe biden
here is aoc saying not we don't need two
we don't need four we don't need six we
need 10 trillion dollars
we're talking about realistically uh 10
trillion dollars over 10 years
and um i know that may be an eye-popping
figure for some people but we need to
understand that
we are in a devastating economic moment
millions of people in the united states
are unemployed we have
a truly crippled health care system
and a planetary crisis on our hands and
we're the wealthiest nation in the
history of the world so
we can do 10 trillion we can do 10
trillion says aoc who's never run a
business in her life
sure why not after all we can surge that
sorry we can't surge money we can't
search is our insurgency
these morons you want to give these
morons more power i'm never going to get
over that i'm never going to get over
the fact there are so many morons who
want to give morons power it's
incredible to me
by the way james clyburn he's admitting
that this infrastructure build this 2
trillion
infrastructure bill contains no
infrastructure he is explaining
it has to do with that kid now children
it has to be
taken care of the elderly i don't
understand
that we aren't eskimos we aren't going
to be
carrying out elderly people is that
infrastructure that's what i'm saying
and does it blur the line
so that you're losing support you might
otherwise get
if you kept it just focusing on that it
says the american
jobs plan the american jobs plan
this is all about jobs it's not just
about
billing uh buildings okay so in other
words yeah this is just us spending a
butt load of money
and democrats are all for it why not
there are no limits okay meanwhile i
have not commented on this matt gates
story all week because the details are
still coming out
but if indeed he was moving miners
across state lines to have sex with them
that is a criminal act you should go to
jail that's my entire take
you got it that's the whole take as far
as the question is whether he's being
extorted he claims that he was being
extorted
by somebody um you know that will
come out in the wash as well i have a
very consistent rule on these things
if you commit a crime you should go to
jail for the crime
and if you were extorted then that
person should go to jail for the crime
so
people have been asking like what do you
think about this that's what i think
about it i have no other thoughts
if andrew cuomo committed a crime he
should go to jail anybody who commits
crime should go to jail i have a very
consistent standard on this stuff
according to abc news the federal
investigation targeting republican
representative matt gates is
specifically looking into whether he and
an associate in his home state of
florida provided cash or other things of
value to women they had sex with
after connecting online the new york
times first reported on thursday evening
gates associate former local politician
joel greenberg was indicted last year
for allegedly trafficking a teenage girl
for sex in 2017
the doj is also trying to determine
whether gates had sex with the 17 year
old according to sources
greenberg plead not guilty to the
charges
the details of the investigation were
first reported by the new york times two
days after the paper revealed an
investigation
was underway gates office did not
respond to requests for comment earlier
this week gates insisted on fox news he
never had a relationship with a 17 year
old
he said such allegations were totally
false according to the times
investigators believe greenberg met a
woman through certain websites and
introduced some of them to gates as
recently as 2019 and 2020
gates and greenberg told women to meet
them at hotels in florida laying out how
much they're willing to pay beforehand
the newspaper said adding the party
drugs may also have been used by gates
and others
at times it's his office that said matt
gates has never paid for sex
that gates refused to all the disgusting
allegations completely med gates has
never been on any such websites
whatsoever
matt gates cherishes the relationships
in his past and looks forward to
marrying
the love of his life so all this is
going to come out in the wash he's under
investigation
we'll find out sooner rather than later
exactly where things stand on that okay
final note
before we end our week here what a week
it has been
final note the evidence is additionally
coming out in the
george floyd case and as it turns out
there's pretty powerful evidence
according to andy mccarthy at national
review that george floyd resisted arrest
there's also a fair bit of evidence that
one of the other people in the car
with george floyd may have been his drug
dealer so the defense is starting to put
up its case
watch over the course of the next week
as the media attempt to elide
the case completely they'll cover the
prosecution they will not cover the
defense you will not know the jurors are
hearing a pretty shaded version
of what happened that day so that if
derek calvin is acquitted it will be
blamed on american racism rather than on
the
very complicated fact patterns of this
particular case alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of the ben shapiro show first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's show every friday
he's got an exciting evening planned for
you so head on over to dailywire.com
this evening at 7 pm eastern tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam's psy events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew klavan host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin